our next guests were massive stars of
the 90s music scene and they're still
going strong they are the fun-loving
criminals they're back with a brand new
album another mimosa I mean why not it's
nearly nine o'clock and they're heading
out on tour as well let's take a listen
to some of their biggest hits to date
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I'm pleased a Huey Brian and Frank
from the fun-loving criminals are in the
studio is now good morning morning I
mean it's not very rock and roll is it
having to get up before 9:00 a.m. well
what makes you think we went to sleep
[Laughter]
and say tell us Huey about the new album
another mimosa well we got an idea in
our heads that we wanted to make some
more original music and when we did our
first mimosa record was where after we'd
done our first two records and we
produce our own music so for us to kind
of recenter or recalibrate the Machine
we decided to take a couple cover songs
that we really loved you know all three
of us your mom actually picked one and
and just kind of concentrate on
producing those and then get our chops
up for the next record so this is kind
of like the record before the record
there's another one in the pipe there's
another one coming yeah so for some of
our younger viewers who might know I've
got got you when you when you first came
I mean how would you describe the kind
of the fun-loving criminals saying
because I remember when the first album
came out I mean it hit you like a boat a
kick to the stomach it was so different
there was some hip-hop in there there
was some jazz that rock I mean it was it
would crossed a number of genres a lot
of sounds from New York City you know
all the music we heard growing up in New
York you know on the same block you
could hear rock and roll next to Latin
music reggae and that's just what we
sort of infused and we figured we didn't
know if we wanted a career in the music
business area let's just do what we know
what we can do and be honest about it
and if that works great and next thing
we know it worked and you've always done
that we don't follow the trend full of
in criminals we do what we do you like
it great you don't like it great you
know that's how we roll it's quite
interesting because we were talking
during the break there about this tour
that you've just started you had your
opening night up in Birmingham and how
touring has changed in years you're
calling it the gentlemen's tour now my
story
yeah we just go out weekend's well
that's when you want a party anyway not
wants to party on a Sunday Monday
Tuesday well so part from people at Sky
I've been told yeah well just it just on
just on ice me it's confession time
I mean you know
your music provided the soundtrack to at
least a couple of years of me getting
pretty wasted and I'm supporting you
guys when you were known as hellraisers
by it then I suspect you kind of maybe
miss those days but occasionally we left
them we were very fortunate in the
regard that we came up as they say
before the advent of social media and
before everybody having a camera phone
so a lot of things you know we've said
confessions that kind of bristled a
little bit because I don't know nothing
no one has anything on videotape but
that kind of thing allowed us to kind of
not get away with stuff but do stuff
without everybody watching and you see
the younger musicians coming up now that
everybody's watching their every move
and you can see that they don't want to
put a foot wrong as if they do they kind
of get cancelled they call it so we were
lucky in the respect that we could sow
Wild Oats and have fun and not have it
be so you know ridiculed it's
interesting I'm going to a gig now is a
different experience and you mentioned
social media there do you find that
there's a lot of that going on a lot of
phones recording you rather than
actually some let's watch our show I
mean they like they're doing a lot more
of this well might be a generational
thing I do see people video things a lot
but I don't see people watching them
back after the fact yeah no one says hey
watch this entire concert I went to use
my phone that doesn't happen too often
so people come to your gigs and enjoy
the experience rather than like yeah and
the single day like Etta of course I'm
you know from the Happy Mondays I mean
tell us about it tell us a bit about the
record in this relative for quite some
time and we were when we got daylight
going we thought that needs a strong
husky female voice to help the core sale
so we asked for a letter and she's an
absolute sweetheart so she jumped
straight on it and I'm hoping we got
some shows coming up Manchester's coming
up and she's the queen of Manchester so
fingers crossed she might make a guest
appearance yeah just looking at some of
the places you're going to mention
Manchester there there's a South Hampton
of Prague Burnley in Copenhagen and
Hamburg as well
so you go it you're going across to
Europe they were like mid-century scandi
furniture so he always
do you find and how do you find the
audiences in Europe differ to the UK
it's a lot of times we play in the UK
often enough to see people two or three
times a year yeah you know and when we
go into Europe yeah in Europe it's
usually look once a year kind of things
so they really save it up you know and
that's always great when you can go
someplace you haven't been in a year or
two and the people are really excited to
see you and it makes it makes for us a
really great you know experience to play
music it's lovely to go back around and
we just play Glasgow barrel ons and we
didn't know they gave us a Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame Award because we'd sold out
we've done it about 18 times and they
come on and give us the words lovely to
see everybody rejoicing in that you know
there are a couple confused Millennials
like behind you that is very subtle King
thank you so much